he's terry francona the Indians manager
they've won 13 in a row skip how are you
this morning hello dan how are you you
should be in a great mood well I tried
try to be all the time I like coming to
the ballpark but I get your point it's
it's been a nice little stretch here and
you know what you know yeah like my boss
was Chris was he told me the other day
goes hey enjoy it man just because it
doesn't happen that often what's the
pressure like compared to Boston oh well
you know what it means I think what
you're referring to maybe some of the
outside you know the external things
that you deal with the Boston because
you know when I came to Cleveland you
know I think I made it pretty clear I
didn't want to come here to go to
pasture you know and all every game
means just as much here you know but but
i do think here in Cleveland get to deal
more with baseball and less with the
external things that nas many fires to
put out which I'm okay with the mood of
the city in Cleveland is what now or has
it changed well I mean shoot getting to
watch the you know the Cavs game 7 that
Sunday night and then give watch the
parade what three days later those
people were ecstatic it was really fun
to watch I mean you know I the way that
the city poured out its feelings for the
team and then to see the way the Cavs
hamblin I I thought was really cool and
I was thrilled for the city you know I
haven't I don't pretend to have grown up
there but I've been there long enough to
care and it's pretty cool and I'm glad
for the businesses downtown and things
like that because you know Cleveland's
got pushed around a little bit now it's
like maybe they're pushing back but does
it put more pressure on you now to win
as a baseball team or is it less
pressure because the city finally got a
championship this is different than
Boston they had championships in other
sports they were just looking one for
one with the red sox yeah but you know
what Dan that doesn't really doesn't
enter into anything we do I mean we we
are you know we we have set our goals
high inside the clubhouse here you know
if you start letting external things
get to you shame on us you know I mean
we need to win winnings hard enough you
know if you're trying to win because the
football team and the basketball team
have a one that that's really tough so
we just need you know our goal is to go
beat the blue jays today we start doing
any more than that and it gets a little
harder than its supposed to be talking
to Terry Francona the Indians manner if
you're joining a stand Patrick show do
you do anything different though when
you're on this hot streak no nothing I
mean I mean should this is such a long
road trip like you know I kid around but
I mean I ran out underwear in Atlanta so
you know we got a couple more days here
and you know the biggest thing is is
like everything just try to be
consistent you know whether you're going
good going bad you know i mean if people
come into our Clubhouse and they don't
know if we're hot or cold i would say
that's probably an accomplishment do you
send somebody out of clubby to get you
underwear on the road no no it doesn't
matter who you kidding me i can't tell
what's clean or dirty anything the way I
dress he doesn't matter anyway I just
all my stuff ends up on the floor
whatever looks wearable I just pick it
up and where'd you have season tickets
to the calves don't you yeah and I'm not
there a ton but I'm glad I got him
because I love going when we're there
and when I'm away in the winter I give
the tickets to you know maybe people in
the organization or guy the clubhouse
guys or trainers the guys in for office
they love going to the game so kind of
get a kick out of that too but I I love
going when I'm there or when you know
when I'm in town I know that you were
Michael Jordan's manager in winter ball
in Arizona but could you imagine lebron
james as a baseball player no but I
could sure imagine him as a tight end I
mean my goodness maladies you know and I
love I go the games probably 45 minutes
an hour early and I just cuz I like to
watch the interaction between the
players watch them warm up things like
that and watching him prepare and just
watching him pound I mean he's just you
know it amazes me what he is able to do
and you know just the way he gets his
teammates involved in the way he passes
and
just how he must condition himself to
just put himself through that year after
year after year it's amazing to me I
also saw what's the thing with popsicles
what's going on are you like just had a
craving for popsicles but is this like a
regular it or not well there-there
there-there grape flavored supposedly
they're healthy so I kind of figured
what one God one's helping 16 s got to
be really healthy late who said they
were a healthy they're full of sugar
that's what it says on the box they
don't lie babies on the internet gotta
be true but other Club ease the club
ease they they stock my refrigerator
with popsicles and grapes and so at
night because I just I kind of go off
the deep end at night during the season
matches the way it is so I eat grapes
and popsicles and the worst thing I have
some is I get a stomachache and that's
not if that's worst thing I'm okay wait
that's going off the deep end is having
grapes and popsicles that's what I mean
I just because I eat I mean like I just
you know you know you get on the road or
when your whole my king of sleep you
know just it's just the way this during
the season I'm sure it's with every
manager but instead of peanut butter
sandwiches or something or nachos I've
kind of least corralled it to where it's
semi healthy yeah but I saw where you
almost threw up Yates so many of those
plow 16 is a bit much come on I had
spent the night in my office and because
it was one of those late games early
arrivals so I stayed in moms and you
know one thing led to another and i
looked up in the morning and when the
guys came in they're like hey man look
at all these popsicle sticks and i
didn't even tell that I'd thrown a
couple of them away it might have been
more what are the sleeping arrangements
in your office there's a little pullout
couch but but you know what's pretty
cool is I just got a new one haven't
even seen it yet and so I'm kind of
excited to see what what this will be
like cuz I got new furniture in there
I'm pretty fired up about look at you
okay yeah I know I know you're living
the life i live in the line hey congrats
good run for you and always great to
talk to you damn thanks take care man
all right that's Terry Francona Indians
manager joins us courtesy of the
Continental Tire coaches corner or
manage
Corner their last loss June fifteenth
four days before the cavs won the NBA
funds the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience